en este vídeo vamos a hablar de la
estructura del sistema nervioso el
sistema nervioso está dividido en dos
partes estructurales principales la
primera parte es el sistema nervioso
central y la segunda parte es el sistema
nervioso periférico y estos dos a su vez
están divididos en otras dos partes el
sistema nervioso central está formado
principalmente por el encéfalo que está
en la cabeza que voy a colorear aquí y
también está formado por la médula
espinal que voy a colorear en azul es
esta estructura larga y tubular que baja
por la columna el encéfalo se divide en
varias partes aquí sólo mencionaré las
principales ya que es un vídeo
introductorio aquí está una vista
lateral del encéfalo del lado izquierdo
toda esta parte superior que se muestra
con varios colores se llama cerebro es
la parte más grande del encéfalo si
vemos el encéfalo desde arriba como en
esta imagen no alcanzamos a ver las
partes que están abajo solo vemos el
cerebro y podemos ver que está dividido
en dos partes
una parte izquierda y una derecha a esas
partes les llamamos hemisferios
cerebrales como una media esfera y
tenemos un hemisferio izquierdo y un
hemisferio derecho en esta imagen de
aquí vemos la parte media del encéfalo
como si hubiéramos cortado el encéfalo
por la mitad y hubiéramos separado el
hemisferio izquierdo y el hemisferio
derecho aquí veríamos el hemisferio
izquierdo toda esta parte de arriba es
el cerebro o uno de los hemisferios
cerebrales
la parte de abajo más pequeña está
dividida en otras dos partes primero voy
a dibujar los contornos de esta parte de
aquí esta parte está conectada con la
médula espinal y se llama tronco
encefálico voy a escribirlo tronco
encefálico es toda esta parte de aquí
que conecta al cerebro con la médula
espinal el tronco encefálico a su vez
está dividido en tres partes más
pequeñas la parte de arriba que se
conecta con el cerebro se llama
mesencéfalo la parte de enmedio se llama
protuberancia de bar olio y la parte
debajo de la protuberancia de bar olio y
que conecta con la médula espinal se
llama bulbo raquídeo o medula oblonga da
y la última parte pero no menos
importante es esta parte que está atrás
del tronco encefálico y conectado con él
esta parte se llama sede velo a veces
nos referimos a las estructuras
cerebrales según los nombres de las
estructuras de las que se formaron en el
embrión
este es un diagrama de un embrión humano
que está desarrollando su cerebro aquí
esta parte de arriba se llama cerebro
anterior también conocido como
prosencéfalo la parte de atrás del
prosencéfalo se llama cerebro medio o
mesencéfalo y en la parte de atrás del
mesencéfalo está el cerebro posterior
también conocido como rompen céfalo el
presente falo va a formar el cerebro el
mesencéfalo será el mes encéfalo que es
esta parte del tronco encefálico y el
rompen cfi lo va a formar el resto del
encéfalo la protuberancia de bar olio el
bulbo raquídeo y el cerebelo por si a
veces se escuchan a alguien referirse a
las estructuras del encéfalo con estos
otros nombres es de aquí de donde
provienen del sistema nervioso en
desarrollo aquí hay un diagrama de la
médula espinal que parece un tubo largo
que se encuentra en la columna hay
varias estructuras que surgen de la
médula espinal de las que hablaremos en
un momento estas son las partes que
componen la mayor parte del sistema
nervioso central y todo lo que no está
en el sistema nervioso central
en el sistema nervioso periférico el
sistema nervioso central se llama así
porque se encuentra en el centro del
cuerpo de forma similar llamamos así al
sistema nervioso periférico porque
abarca todo el resto del cuerpo el
sistema nervioso periférico consiste de
dos tipos de estructuras la primera se
llaman nervios
aquí estoy subrayando este nervio y son
estas estructuras que parecen cuerdas
largas que van por todo el cuerpo
los nervios llevan los acciones de las
neuronas la segunda estructura del
sistema nervioso periférico son los
ganglios los ganglios son estas
protuberancias pegadas a los nervios y
que contienen las sombras de las
neuronas permiten me dibujar esto un
poco diferente en este diagrama de la
médula espinal que tiene estos nervios
que salen de ella aquí hay una de esas
protuberancias o ganglios que contienen
las tomas de algunas neuronas en el
sistema nervioso periférico algunos de
éstos acciones que viajan por estos
nervios llevan información hacia el
sistema nervioso central desde la
periferia y llevan la información en
estado
desde la periferia y cuando hacen esto
las llamamos neuronas aferentes que
llevan información o señales nerviosas
hacia el sistema nervioso central otras
neuronas enviarán acciones con
información en la dirección opuesta
lejos del sistema nervioso central hacia
la periferia y las neuronas que llevan
información desde el sistema nervioso
central hacia la periferia se llaman
neuronas y gerentes existen muchos de
estos nervios que se encuentran por todo
el cuerpo y podemos clasificarlos de
varias formas pero normalmente las
clasificamos como los nervios craneales
que son nervios que salen principalmente
del encéfalo y pasan a través del cráneo
a medio camino entre el sistema nervioso
central y la periferia o los nervios
periféricos pueden ser nervios espinales
o raquídeo si éstos salen de la médula
espinal y pasan a través de la columna
en su camino entre el sistema nervioso
central y la periferia
aquí dibujé sólo unos pocos pero de
hecho hay muchos de estos nervios se
encuentran por pares en ambos lados del
cuerpo
hay 12 pares de nervios craneales y 31
pares de nervios espinales así vemos los
diagramas de la médula espinal podemos
ver que estos nervios espinales
realmente se forman de estas dos partes
que se llaman raíces del nervio espinal
hay una raíz adelante y una raíz atrás
en este otro diagrama se ve la parte de
atrás esta es la raíz de atrás que tiene
el ganglio la manera en que funcionan
estas raíces espinales es que las
neuronas aferentes que llevan las
señales hacia el sistema nervioso
central viajan por la raíz de la parte
de atrás y las neuronas diferentes que
llevan la información lejos del sistema
nervioso central viajan por la raíz
nerviosa que está adelante luego ambas
se juntan en la médula espinal y ahí lo
llamamos nervios mixtos porque ahí se
mezclan las neuronas diferentes y a
gerentes como cualquiera de estos
nervios viaja desde su origen proximal
proximal significa que está cerca del
centro del cuerpo hacia su terminación
distal distal significa alejado o lejos
del centro del cuerpo todos los nervios
se van
sucesivamente se ramifica se ramifica y
se vuelve a ramifican en ramas cada vez
más finas hasta que abarque en todas las
partes del cuerpo las partes proximales
del nervio son tan grandes que las
podemos ver a simple vista pero una vez
que llegamos a las partes distal es
cuando ya se han ramificado muchas veces
los nervios se vuelven microscópicos
éstos llegan a todas partes del cuerpo
conectándolo todo al sistema nervioso
central y esto se cumple para casi todos
los nervios craneales y espinales wii y
casi se me olvida hablarles de este
último diagrama de los nervios craneales
este es un diagrama del encéfalo visto
desde abajo y todas estas cosas que
lucen como pequeñas cuerdas que salen
del encéfalo son los nervios craneales
van a pasar a través del cráneo
alejándose del encéfalo hacia la
periferia no voy a dibujar todos aquí
pero hay muchos de estos nervios
craneales que atraviesan el cráneo esta
fue sólo una introducción y veremos esto
con más detalle en futuros vídeos